this morning The New Yorker reports new
details of an alleged 2006 affair
between the president and a former
Playboy model and how it was allegedly
covered up the magazine cites a report
that American media incorporated paid
former model Karen McDougal 150,000
dollars for the rights for her story
before the 2016 election ami owns the
National Enquirer tabloid former AMI
employees told the New Yorker the
company's CEO David pecker routinely
purchases then does not print negative
stories a practice known as catch and
kill pecker is a friend of President
Trump one former top a my editor said we
had stories and we bought them knowing
full well they were never going to run
he added we never printed a word about
Trump without his approval
a spokesperson for am i said McDougald
story was never published because they
didn't find it credible
in a statement to The New Yorker a White
House spokesperson says the president
denies having an affair with mcdougal
calling it fake news